um okay the us army after giving
so much notice and giving every
opportunity for service members to go
and get themselves vaccinated with the
covet vaccine is at the end of the grace
period and the u.s army is going to
start discharging covid vaccine refusers
effective immediately npr reporting
u.s army soldiers who refuse to be
vaccinated for covid will soon be
discharged the military branch announced
yesterday wednesday the army said it
will quote immediately begin separating
soldiers from the service who refuse to
be vaccinated or who don't have an
approved or pending request for
exemption
secretary of the army christine warmuth
said army ready readiness depends on
soldiers who are prepared to train
deploy fight and win our nation's wars
unvaccinated soldiers present risk to
the force and jeopardize readiness
soldiers who are discharged for refusing
to be vaccinated quote will not be
eligible for involuntary separation pay
and may even have to return unearned
special or incentive pay
now the right is framing this as we are
dramatically weakening i don't know why
i'm doing the alex jones voice we are
dramatically weakening
the military and we are going to be more
beta rather than alpha in fighting wars
which they claim they don't want to
fight anyway but as of january 26th as
the article points out 96 percent of
active duty troops were completely
vaccinated
uh 3 300 soldiers have refused
5 900 have temporary exemptions
and
those are temporary in the sense that
the requests are still being reviewed
this is really not a big deal it's time
you need a bunch of vaccines to be in
the military this is the latest vaccine
you need it's not controversial we've
gone through the list i'm not going to
do it again is it 10
15 depending on where you're serving it
can be closer to 20 different vaccines
that you have to get when you're in the
military if you won't follow a simple
service-wide vaccine mandate that is
like the 13th or the 18th or whatever
it's not unique it's not we've never had
any vaccine requirements and now here's
one you've got to get
they all got in line for all the other
vaccines when they enlisted um it's just
time to say you're not fit for military
service oh i'm not taking this one
vaccine because of my rights or my
religion or come on guys come on now one
thing that i heard from some service
members about and i did a little
research into this and it does appear to
be true
is um a bill was passed
taking uh dishonorable discharges off
the table for vaccine refusers
so what i'm hearing from some of our
viewers who are in the military uh is
that there are people who have been sort
of wanting to get out for a little while
and they're taking this as an
opportunity now again we're only talking
about 3 300 unvaccinated with no
exemption right now
so it's like a tiny tiny percentage of
individuals and some fraction of those
may be refusing the vaccine not because
they're actually against it but because
they want
a way to get out without a dishonorable
discharge so
that may be a factor to some degree but
i i don't think it's a dominant thing
but anecdotally it does seem to exist
from what i'm hearing but there's really
nothing controversial here it is not
going to affect overall military
readiness it's not going to affect uh in
any material way
the massive fighting force that the
united states has and it really
shouldn't even be getting the attention
that it's getting because it's not
never needed vaccines and now you do
like i said it's you always needed 12
now you need 13 or depending on where
you're serving you needed 17.
now you need 18. it's not a big deal and
it shouldn't be made into one and the
military has been saying for a long time
this is exactly what we're going to do
and now they're doing it it would be
more of a problem i would argue if they
said that this is what they were going
to do and then they failed to do it
uh they promised this was the path and
they're doing it and it makes perfect
sense if you disagree with me let me
know you can find me on twitter at d
pacman we're going to take a very short
break we really have a fantastic program
for you today
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video